for nearly a month's indigenous
communities have been blocking the
bridge leading to the town of laraqueri
in the rest of puno region of Southern
Peru
they're demanding the resignation of
President dinaboloarte
it's her fault that's why we are out
here on the streets because she betrayed
us she's killing our brothers with
bullets and all we have are slingshots
a short distance away the Army has
converted the town's bullfighting ring
into a military base they say the state
of emergency allows them to be here but
they refuse to be interviewed on camera
nevertheless I ask if it's true that
they plan to begin clearing the highways
on Monday
an officer confirms that's indeed their
mission some locals become angry and
insist they have a right to paralyze the
region to pressure the President to
resign and call for national elections
we want to exercise a constitutional
right which is National Insurrection I
come in peace but I tell you man to man
if you come here looking to confront us
things will be very different
before we were afraid but not anymore if
they want to kill us let them kill us I
have sons in the army look how they want
to use my children
the deployment of the Army and the vow
by many combatant indigenous communities
to resist attempts to end their
prolonged National strike has sharply
increased tensions in puno
and not just on land this is Lake
Titicaca the home of the udos more than
two thousand of them actually live on
the lake this is where the Inca Empire
was founded long before the Spaniards
ever came here
Rita suanya lives on one of the scores
of tiny floating islands where locals
make a living from tourism
but the current crisis is keeping
tourists away she says president
poluarte needs to resign to end the
conflict
we are the uro and we're also from puno
we are the children of the lake where
Peru was founded so how dare she say
that puno is not Peru she has offended
us
[Music]
however unpopular the president the
ongoing strikes and roadblocks are
taking their toll it's a battle that may
depend on which side can resist the
longest
to see a Newman Al Jazeera puno Peru